top Biden officials and rail company
employees avoiding a town hall in East
Palestine concerned residents searching
for answers after a toxic train
derailment released toxic chemicals
[Applause]
come on
but the rail company that owns the train
involved didn't hear any of that because
they were too worried about their own
safety citing potential threats to their
employees that they had been sent so the
city's mayor also says Transportation
secretary Buddha judge is missing in
action
from the White House
the head of the EPA did visit Ohio to
assess the situation he assured the
city's water was safe but a Republican
senator wants him to prove it
that the EP administrator wants to stand
here and tell people that the tap water
is safe by all means they should be
willing to drink it
Okay so
we talked a little bit about the lack of
trust yesterday but Greg then you have
this situation where the residents say
they just want to be heard they all go
to the town hall the federal the
government showed up state and federal
government but the railroad didn't they
said they were worried about their
safety and violence against them I think
it always goes back to that question
we've talked about this before when the
White House is looking at a problem is
this a big story or is it just a big
story on Fox
and that if you look at what we've
talked about for a year whether it was
fentanyl or the crime wave or uh the
laptop story or the Border you have to
drag them Kicking and Screaming because
it it hurts them so much to admit that
maybe we are on to something we've been
you know this story languished for days
nobody was covering it until the local
news and then we picked it up but they
they see it on our Network and they go
is this real what's really strange about
this is that there was a movie filmed
here uh White Noise which is based on a
Don de lilio book is that how you say it
I look at the liberal because obviously
she's a fan but anyway
it was about it's same thing about a
chemical spill right and and then it
happens in this town where they filmed
it where extras were played by the
citizens is this a coincidence is it
deliberate imagine after Jaws you know
in Montauk a shark appeared and killed
the exact same people or after Pretty
Woman Julia Roberts became a hooker or
Scent of a Woman Al Pacino suddenly goes
blind it's a it's a very strange thing
but I would end on this point imagine if
this was a republican Administration
there would be hearings accusations of a
cover-up an impeachment instead it's
treated less like a disaster more like a
stain on a rug yeah no offense Jesse I
know rugs are expensive
yeah I can't afford
okay um
I'm concerned that and I said yesterday
dewine's good guy I am not impressed
with the wine
I am not impressed that he wasn't there
last night Norfolk Southern wasn't there
okay the head of the EPA says the
water's safe but I I agree with J.D
Vance make him drink it okay when you
can't put your kids in that water to
take a bath you can't wash your own hair
I mean I worry these people are are in a
basically poor area and what we've got
is a disaster and dewine has to get
together with the president and have
FEMA declare this a disaster area we can
put illegals and high-end hotels in New
York City we can provide these American
citizens with homes when none of this is
due to their fault none of this had to
do with any wrongdoing on their part and
someone please explain to me why
Seminola wheat why frozen vegetables are
on the same train as Vinyl chloride
hazardous waste that if there isn't
derailment you get a plume like that I
don't need to tell anybody what a plume
like that means and what the long-term
impact of that is going to be so this is
an environmental chemical Hazard and it
requires the government to show up and I
don't want to hear he didn't ask me I
didn't ask him either show up or give up
your position as someone in government
because we pay you and and one last
thought
we always As Americans thought that the
Cavalry was coming that we are protected
that our government has our back State
local Federal we can't even get their
attention Buddha judge tweets after 10
days then blames Trump because of
Congress has passed a law that required
Trump to do something when I then did a
deep dive to find out that if Buddha
judge is so upset about it he's had two
years to make a difference and change it
to make it better this is a failure on
the part of everyone in government shame
on all of them Jessica the EPA puts out
a lot of information about what women
who are pregnant should and should not
eat and what they should and should not
do and one of the things I was just
reading this here I'm like well I know
that they're saying it's safe but if I
were a pregnant woman or had young
children I don't think I'd want to be
there I mean I was upset that I couldn't
eat salami for nine months let alone
living in an environment like that I
would be out of there as soon as I could
but I would have the means to be able to
get out of there
majority of handling a management crisis
well is showing up literally standing
there and taking it that's what your job
is supposed to be and these people
actually sounded pretty sane about it
they said we just want to be heard right
we actually believe you there are people
I saw online that have gotten their own
chemical test strips and they're testing
their own water but you better believe
if they're if you're at home with kids
you're not putting them in the bathtub
with this and it as someone my dad died
of a 911 cancer because the environment
right and we were told it's safe no
problem stay in Tribeca and I don't want
that to happen to anybody else and
there's enough money it's a small enough
area and I know that it's gotten about
115 miles from there that you can move
those people and you put them in hotels
you know uh the Pittsburgh papers the
Cleveland papers they did a very good
job covering this get them to those
cities and figure out whatever you need
to figure out and that's why dewine
should be in touch and take whatever
FEMA dollars are coming that way you can
allocate them however you want if you
don't need disaster relief in a
traditional way but you need to make
sure those are reallocation dollars get
it done because if one person dies that
is such a stain on your record and it's
also just a stain on your soul that you
stood up there and you said it's fine
here for these people and that's what
Aaron Brockovich was talking about
yesterday on air as well you just
um Jesse I'll give a last question to
you but I wanted to point out that I
read this article I think this is the
New York Times
um this guy's quoted in there he's 28.
he said he and his wife are talking
about moving away for good but the quote
he said is this town was starting to
come back and now it's just going to die
it breaks your heart yeah
to to jump off of what Greg said this
story the fact that fox is driving the
story tells you so much about who Fox is
and
what other people think Fox is you have
a million dollar rail Tycoon who's
spreading so much money around
Washington and Ohio that his lobbyists
have done whatever they want to make
these trains go as fast as hell and this
thing derails and Spills these hazardous
chemicals everywhere he lights it on
fire
and then has his team go around knocking
on doors saying we'll test the air in
the water if you sign this liability
waiver hundreds of people have already
signed liability waivers so they're not
going to be able to Sue this company and
the EPA is lying the EPA never tested
the water the EPA never tested the air
you know who did the tests
the rail company that spilled this thing
hired a private contractor to do the
testing and the private contractor the
same contractor they hired during
Katrina the BP oil spill every time a
big Industrial company does anything to
the environment into these nice
neighborhoods they hire the same company
who says
yeah everything's fine go back to work
go back to school that's a huge Scandal
and Biden's not here Mr empathy mayor
Pete's not here
and you wouldn't think Fox would cover
this story right if everything you know
about Fox you know corporate Fox doesn't
care about the little guy this reverses
everything about the impression people
have of this company and this tells you
a lot about who's telling the truth
except for you people still see you
people still think I'm a jerk yeah
it's the face
[Laughter]
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now